[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
is thursday october 27th 2016. roughly
the 25 year anniversary of the first
apple laptops and of course as we've all
seen today apple's unveiled the new
macbook pros with the oled touch bar and
the huge new trackpad the new keyboards
the new displays and everything they're
pretty sick and i have a full video on
these new machines coming up in the next
couple days so definitely subscribe to
make sure you see that but in the
meantime i got a fun one for you i got
to spend some time with apple's senior
vp of software engineering mr hair force
one himself craig federighi so shout out
to craig for taking the time to answer
my questions and enjoy this exclusive
interview
okay so
you've had a lot of time behind the
scenes obviously to put information
together to make these
as awesome as they are i've been working
on them for a long time exactly it's
really exciting to see them so my i
started my youtube channel on this
laptop the laptop of this hp pavilion
dv7 i'm very sorry
it was it was a great laptop at the time
and it helped me out a lot the webcam
made the videos
and at the top of that laptop it had
this little function bar with like a
volume slider and some little brightness
buttons didn't change or anything right
but this is like next level having these
buttons that change based on what app
you're using at the time
why now why why 2016 for for us to
arrive at these sweet oled retina
displays yeah i mean a lot of it came
together in terms of the
the technology being just right to
really pull this off in this kind of
form factor with this id the quality of
the display i mean you wanted it to feel
just completely native to the keyboard
and completely real and be so responsive
i mean we were able to take
so much that we've learned in the
hardware for ios devices and even so
much of the security model of ios like
for touch id and incorporate some of our
custom silicon to make it happen so a
lot of things had to come together to
make this uh possible it's exciting to
finally have it out yeah okay okay so
similar to touch id in the iphone uh
this will get better with time right so
this works great with a lot of first
party apple apps look great with safari
uh look great with final cut what are
you most looking forward to seeing maybe
in a year from now when we have these
and developers get their hands on it
what kind of stuff should we expect to
see yeah
what's been really awesome is we brought
some developers in
over the past month and we just showed a
small subset of of the ones that had
come in and already started doing work
and they have a lot of great ideas i
mean i i don't know if you you notice
like the dj pro guy who was like you
know multi-fingering
all over it and you know that's the kind
of creative use that that really i mean
it's so exciting when we develop a
product and we know
we have our vision of what we can do
with it with our apps and then you go
well but we know that inherently this is
a device with so much potential because
it's just a versatile multi-touch
display but it is when you get it in the
hands of these developers and you see
like we didn't think of that yeah that's
just awesome so
i'm i'm really excited about what we've
seen so far and i think you know of
course a lot of people will do you know
buttons and sliders but i think there'll
be this next wave where people say hey
this is like this is like custom
hardware like you can create the control
that is supports the best mechanic for
whatever it is that you want to do in
your app and whether that's a game doing
something really novel music is so
awesome for the kind of real-time
capability so uh it's going to be great
but i i'm
really excited about how fast it's
already happening i think day one
you get one of these it's going to be
great sweet so you've had a lot of time
like i said behind the scenes you've
been working on it for a while i'm sure
there's a lot that you could tell me
that you didn't say on stage give me
give me one thing about these laptops
these macbook pros
that we didn't see on stage it's been
tough because all of us uh have to keep
them secret the whole time i couldn't
you know couldn't let my family see them
the times when my wife would come by and
i'd like throw a cloth over my you know
sort of dive over my laptop
and uh so it you know the treat for us
is finally after we've been working on
these for
years to finally be able to go home and
say here it is we've we've done it so um
it's it's uh
it's it's wonderful to have them out
here and and i from what i've seen so
far i think uh
many folks are going to enjoy them all
right you get to time travel
back to
1999. you're undercover craig no one
knows you're craig you don't have the
hair you're just
in no i just hold my hair right i did
have hair back in 19. okay so let's just
say no one knows your craig in 1999.
that was true you get to bring one
current gen apple device to prove you're
from the future what should you bring
wow
that is a heck of a question
i can't bring them all huh just one just
the best one just your favorite one oh
well that's that's a whole different
question okay i think proving you're
from 2016.
you know honestly it's a it's a it's an
unoriginal answer but i would think if i
were just proving i was from the future
you'd have to bring an iphone because i
mean just the raw
the the the density of capability
in your hand i mean obviously every time
i look at one of these and i think how i
would have seen this through 1999 eyes i
mean it would have been
i mean the throat power book was pretty
unbelievable right that's pretty
impressive but the iphone is
yeah i think if there were just one i
think it would be i mean the fact the
number of things that you can do with
the device in your hand are things that
i think
all of us have been amazed at the
transformative effect of things
computing tasks that we used to think
well i'm only going to do that sitting
down at a desk with a full computer and
now people are like what the heck i'm
doing it on you have your notes here on
a phone right right you take photos on
your phone so talking to siri all that
stuff so but i don't i'm not saying i
have a favorite i like i love them all
fair absolutely that's fair
that was awesome i appreciate all of
your time
that's really exciting stuff and
hopefully we get through this again
sometime legit that'd be great awesome
thank you
[Music]
you